hello reject nation Greg Alba here
Andrew here from the movie source
channel my hair is crazier than a door
it's always crazy especially crazy
because andrew is helping us shoot
something that I don't want to give
anything away but we could be out doors
and was really windy but now we're here
cuz I found out some movie clips from
infinity war drop people and I was like
alright let's check it out cuz we're all
about ruining scenes for us right yeah
that's all we care about before we go
into that I wanted to give a shout out
patient the day shadow for a Delia
Chamberlain because right now she is
doing what Andrew did in the past month
which is she is binging all the Marvel
movies so that way she can be fully
caught up to date a few months ago she
was having surgery and she wasn't able
to catch the last Jedi and the theaters
on time so that's suck she got the whole
thing small for her I'm so happy for you
that this time around you're gonna be
able to catch infinity of war before
everyone gets to ruin it for you my dear
so keep it up I hope you post a starless
reaction because I love the hell out of
you and I love whenever you message us
enjoy yourself at the theater my dear
take care of that foot let's watch the
first clip there's two clips here both
from I think they appeared on Good
Morning America vision okay
the structure is polymorphic right we
had to attach each neuron non non
sequential why didn't you just reprogram
the synapses - were connected because
[Music]
Wow buddy see super short ass clip but I
liked about that are still keeping
Cherie as the smartest one yeah Tony's
smarter than Bruce Lee yeah we've seen
in previous movies if you try and talk
to Tony Stark and Bruce Banner when it
comes to scientific things you kind of
look like a dumbass
yeah he is clearly holding her own when
it comes to and also Bruce Maher was
like cuz we didn't I think of that
yeah like dude she's much she's smarter
than that we the smartest one but the
dialogue it's so good it's so crisp it's
funny it's organic I love how even like
a vision was impressed with her at that
moment yeah you know you can impress
vision you're on the right track and I
mean be obvious what I gather it looks
like she's trying to figure out some way
to get that maybe that keep him alive by
still being able to remove the stone you
know what that would be very important
for vision in this specific movie yep
yeah after the we're nomads gonna come
in Black Widow and Falcon well yeah I'm
into save vision yeah no definitely
because there may be that they teased
that seen the trailer like as if vision
is gonna die there but he's not I think
he's gonna get saved and so in that
moment the really got to get this out of
kete vision a lot and they go to Wakanda
exactly exactly
alright let's move on to the next one
which a black order fight scene it's
only 30 seconds long yeah
[Music]
oh so short that's good I'm glad it was
sure I love the way they portray Falcon
to the Russo brothers halves I mean they
have such respect for each character
that they portray but you can tell they
have an undying love for Falcon Anthony
Mackie he's just so good in this role
and also two dude from the hand-to-hand
fighting that I was seeing it even
though their deal the fighting alien
beings
it just really reminds me a lot of the
Civil War and winter soul winter
soldiers it would be the hand-to-hand
that incredible combat I freaking love
then also too we kind of heard the voice
a little bit of proximate and I believe
that's Carrie [ __ ] doing the voice of
hey that was the big announcement right
yeah Carrie [ __ ] is doing the voice so I
also - in the comics I they're married
actually Proxima midnight and Corvus
glaive so you can tell like yo can I get
that live and get that feel like she's
active she's very concerned for him also
- I think we saw in the clip it looked
like it was magnetically spear came
right back - or when does when the boy
showed us this clip I kind of wish we
didn't get the end of the clip where
they show that they defeat them in this
fight it's like sure I'm sure they win
in a fight or here or there in the movie
the black order they've been hyping them
up they've been building them up but
then you see that cap Falcon and Black
Widow are able to take them down by
themselves I feel like that kind of
lowers the threat level I mean it's just
two members of the Black Order but it
kind of diminishes the threat level just
a little bit for me no I mean you make a
good point but also I think they're
trying to make the point that they were
not expecting Nomad Falcon and Black
Widow I come in it's more of a surprise
attack this is after vision as being
attacked well yeah yeah I think I think
they attack vision and Scarlet Witch and
then all of a sudden Nomad Falcon and
Black Widow command no more so I don't
think they were expecting so maybe
that's what happens I mean we'll have to
see what the super we're gonna see you
next week buddy we're seeing a couple
times next week and I can't wait to you
for watching both times together
I'm bringing the tissues yeah
I'm bringing my flush look all right
let's subscribe to the reject nation you
can click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up that's what a notification bell is
you can check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
and check out and ruin the movie source
channel people he has a great great
YouTube channel keep a look out for his
review of affinity or especially the
spoiler review as you know this guy is
gonna have details to talk about see you
guys soon